so this week on the internet you may
have seen some scary-looking humanoid
robots that look like they were messed
up on horse tranquilizers because if
you're trying to be human you may as
well start out abusing horse
tranquilizers they were actually part of
a competition over the weekend put on by
DARPA the crazy research wing of the
Pentagon two dozen teams from around the
world put the robot through eight
challenges including opening a door
walking through rubble and no joke
driving an ATV the whole idea here was
to get roboticist thinking about how to
better design robots for rescue
situations theoretically if a robot
moves like a human it can better
navigate things like contaminated
nuclear reactors which are obviously
designed with human beings in mind there
are already perfectly good robots that
do this only they run on tracks kind of
like tiny tanks but this means they
can't do things like climate ladder or
Drive an ATV problem is getting a robot
to walk like a human is really really
hard as you might have noticed and these
things are incredibly bulky which is no
good if you want to use them to explore
something like a collapsed mine or
parking garage where robot needs to fit
into tight spaces this brings us to an
interesting question watch the human
body be the inspiration here at all what
if there's a design that doesn't look
anything like a human being but is able
to navigate human structures just as
well it's a question that has sharply
divided the robotics community tracked
vehicles have their advantages and one
day humanoids will have theirs as well
but what if there's a design that
combines both or better yet we can stop
our bickering and realize that maybe all
of them can work in concert rescuers
already use tracked robots and collapsed
mines and once the technology gets to
the point where they aren't 400 pounds
and falling on their faces humanoids may
work for operations that require a human
touch or we can just keep them as they
are for comic relief